what's being worked on now is 3D
bioprinting where you can use what's
called bio Inc and you can actually
print tissue and definitely by the end
of the decade we'll be able to use 3D
bio printers to recover organs I've had
my ankle replaced and that surgery is
just not good back then the technology
wasn't there yet but now if you were to
have or someone out there has like the
same issue and they want to avoid
surgery is we can actually use expanded
stem cells so the stem cell that we grow
in a lab for three to four weeks and
then you can actually use a 3D
bioprinter and you can print this custom
scaffold and you regrow cartilage